this is the crash site about 250
kilometers north of Moscow it's here
where Russia's Aviation agency says the
private jet carrying evgeny pagosian
crashed late on Wednesday evening
the head of the Wagner private military
company was one of the 10 people killed
a man close to the president a fact
Vladimir Putin acknowledged while
offering his condolences
as for this Aviation incident first of
all I want to express my sincere
condolences to the families of all the
victims it is always a tragedy and
indeed if as the primary data indicates
Wagner employees were also there I would
like to note that these are people who
have made a significant contribution to
our common cause
Russian State media have posted this
amateur video that appears to show a
plane that was out of control and
falling to the ground
Aviation monitoring website flight
Trader says the aircraft was flying from
Moscow to Saint Petersburg
investigators are searching the wreckage
for possible causes of the crash
meanwhile back at the Wagner groups
headquarters in St Petersburg people
have been paying tribute to pagosian
and speculation has been rampant on the
streets of the capital Moscow as people
try to figure out what happened
for years the 62 year old pagosian has
been running the Wagner group with
mercenary recruits involved in many
conflicts including Syria and countries
in Africa
his Fighters have also been crucial to
Russia's Battlefield advances in Ukraine
but in June pagosian fell out of favor
with his longtime Ally Vladimir Putin
when he led a failed Mutiny against the
president's commanders of the war in
Ukraine I don't think that the
can change everything because the modus
operandi of Wagner group
was searched during this agreement great
agreement between putting between
lukashanka and between pregosian after
the failed coup in June Russian
President Vladimir Putin has said in the
past that betrayal is an unforgivable
crime many analysts here say the Goshen
Was A Marked Man for publicly
humiliating the Russian government for
now the Russian president has offered
his condolences to the family members of
the 10 victims of the plane crash he
also went on to explain the relationship
he's had since the early 1990s with
Afghani pagosian he said that provision
was a deep man of difficult fate and he
made some serious mistakes in his life
but he achieved the desired results he
also praised the Wagner group for their
efforts and the contributions they made
to the fight against Nazism in Ukraine
for now everyone here is waiting for
officials to wrap up their investigation
into the official cause of the plane
crash
dorsa Jabari Al Jazeera Moscow
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera